the show is set in the early ages of the
northern Song Dynasty in the opening
scene the Empress of the Kingdom dies
due to old age and no one is ready to
replace her as a result the emperor of
the Lao Kingdom launches an attack on
the Song Dynasty disregarding the peace
agreements they had signed they rob
innocent civilians and to execute them
ruthlessly causing utter chaos
witnessing this tragedy a group of
individuals led by cow Fang from the
Beggars sacked come forward to assist
the song Empire Feng uses his
extraordinary martial arts moves to take
down the Liao Army alone later upon
discovering a change in the Liao realm
Fang decides to convey this information
to their sects Chief and by that I mean
the chief of their sect not a chief of
sex on the other hand we are introduced
to a naive Prince from the Dali Kingdom
named duanyu who accidentally comes
across a shrine there he witnesses an
ongoing sword fighting contest between
the leaders of the eastern and western
branches of the Limitless sword sac
Eastern lader's name is zwozie Moo
whereas the Western Leader's name is
shin shuang King for the first few
minutes of the fight shuang King gains
the upper hand but the opponent soon
makes a false move causing the situation
to be reversed in the blink of an eye
this results
emerging Victorious duaneu does not
understand the move and simply finds the
incident amusing when he starts laughing
zuosimu becomes offended and challenges
him to a fight however dwanyu refuses
straight away claiming he has better
things to do meanwhile a girl named
Zhang Ling watches all of this from a
rooftop and enjoys the spectacle until
the one you gets punched at that point
she intervenes and releases her
poisonous mink causing zwozie moo to
become weakened and paralyzed before
leaving she informs zwosemu's disciples
that a rare herb can counteract the
poison before it reaches his heart
elsewhere Fang arrives at The Shaolin
Temple and meets with the chief of the
Beggars sect Wang Jiang Tong who is
currently having a conversation with the
Abbott named Schwan T upon receiving the
news of liao's Realm Wang and Abbott
Swansea discussed the necessary
defensive actions to be taken and also
decide to inform the Dali Kingdom after
the meeting Feng wanders around the main
hall of the Shaolin Temple and Witnesses
a series of fights where a man named
murang Fu emerges Victorious against his
opponents one by one intrigued Feng
decides to test his skills against
murang'thu and jumps into the arena
unlike the previous Challengers he puts
up a tough fight and ultimately utilizes
his impressive skill known as the 18
subduing Dragon Palms to overpower
murang'thil astonishing everyone present
soon the result of the battle is relayed
to Wang in the other abbots who commend
Feng's exceptional Talent Wang then
expresses his intention to pass on his
chief position in the beggar's sect to
Fang he claims that the boy is now
worthy to become the chief hearing this
Abid schwansi is a bit shocked but he
too agrees to support Wang's decision
later that day Abbott Swansea finds a
junior disciple named shushu being
bullied by his fellow seniors it appears
that sushu who is known for his
kind-hearted nature and diversion to
conflict often becomes a target of
bullying among his peers after the
seniors are done with him Abbott Schwann
C talks to shushu in private and shares
with him the knowledge of the 18
subduing Dragon Palms technique he
explains that although the technique may
appear simple each Palm strike possesses
varying levels of strength and force
furthermore he highlights that murang Fu
was defeated by Fang because he failed
to adapt to the fluctuating strengths
within the technique elsewhere dwan Yu
and Zhang Ling stroll through the forest
enjoying each other's company despite
their differing views on serving people
along the way they come across members
of the shenan sect who are preparing
poison in order to confront their
adversary the Limitless sword sect the
one you who was Guided by his Buddhist
beliefs and aversion to violence seeks
to intervene and halt their actions as a
result both of them proceed towards the
shenan sects location and meet with its
leader named sikong Shuan these names
are going to kill me dude
shares the teachings of Buddha and tries
to persuade sikong Schwann to choose
forgiveness over fight however sikong
Shuan suspects the Duan Yeo and Zhang
Lang have ulterior motives and assumes
that they are sent by their enemies as a
result he orders his men to capture them
but to his surprise zhongling uses her
fighting skills to fend off the
attackers and eventually deploys her
mink poisoning all of them a friggin
mink is op on the other side Feng
formulates a strategic plan in case the
Liao sect makes any suspicious moves for
this he dispatches his men to the Border
instructing them to hide themselves and
gather information regarding the
increasing presence and Camp
configuration of the Liao forces during
their discussion Wang walks in and
dismisses everyone else to ensure a
private conversation with Fang he then
recounts Feng's past acts of Bravery his
willingness to sacrifice himself for the
sake of the Beggars sacked filled with
trust and confidence Wang finally
bestows upon Fang the position of Chief
making him the ninth generation leader
of the sect the next scene we see dwan
you and Zhang Ling who are now captured
by sikong Shuan and his men as The Mink
bites everyone Seekonk Shuan demands the
antidote but Zhong Ling claims that only
her father possesses the means to cure
the poison with no options available
sikong Shuan makes the difficult
decision to slice his own hand in order
to prevent the further spread of the
poison after this he compels one you to
ingest a tablet that will apparently
cause his internal organs to rupture
within a week Seekonk Shuan adds that he
will provide its antidote and release
xiangling only when dwanyu returns with
her father to heal them hearing this a
scared one you agrees to complete the
task prior to his departure Zhang Ling
gives him one of her shoes urging him to
present it to her father as proof of his
sincerity she also warns him against
revealing his true identity as it may
put his life in danger although dwan Yu
remains puzzled by her father's hatred
toward the dwan's sect he doesn't ask
much as time is running out following
this he embarks on his journey Crossing
mountains and streams under the cover of
Darkness after walking for some time he
notices a couple approaching a nearby
lake in order to remain hidden he
conceals himself behind a large Stone
and listens in on their conversation it
is revealed that the couple has betrayed
their master and fled their Kingdom they
go on to discuss a rumor about a former
Grand Master who while walking on a
moonlit night witnessed the silhouette
of a dancing sword on a stone wall this
sighting led the sect members to
mistakenly believe that he was an
immortal as dwanyu hears all this he
accidentally makes a noise capturing the
attention of the couple as a result they
give him Chase prompting dwan you to
dash deep into the forest before long he
arrives at a cliff and with no other way
out decides to jump to his Lockheed
Falls inside a cave safely without any
harm to his body upon heading inside the
cave Duan yew comes across a delicate
white statue of a fairy made up of Jade
he finds it to be so beautiful that he
calls it Miss deity beneath the statue
he discovers a message instructing him
to perform a thousand cows on a futon
although the task is an extremely
difficult one Duane decides to go
through with it he bows down with the
utmost respect and starts performing the
couch after an hour as dwanyu concludes
this act of reverence he uncovers a silk
bag hidden within the futon inside it he
finds a message directing him to learn
martial arts and eliminate all members
of the Carefree sect so that this deity
can finally rest in peace this puts to
on you in a tough spot as you cannot
kill anyone being a disciple of Lord
Buddha however he ultimately decides to
carry out the order as he cannot disobey
the commands of the Jade statue after
all loyalty to one's God pales in the
face of sexy mannequins to one you then
explores the surroundings and discovers
that the cave was once a secret Library
unfortunately he finds no books
remaining leading him to assume that the
Carefree sect has already vanished with
this assumption in mind he exits the
cave and resumes his journey towards
Zhang Lang's location meanwhile at the
beggar's Kingdom Wang gathers all the
members and declares Fang as the new
chief of their sect the decision is is
met with Satisfaction by everyone
present including the elders in
celebration of this occasion the sect
organizes a festive event where everyone
indulges in enjoyment the younger
members seize the opportunity to test
their skills against Fang and learn from
him while the elders observe with
admiration appreciating his martial arts
prowess and Noble character on the other
hand Juan Yu continues his journey
through the dense forest and after a
long walk he comes across a tree bearing
a warning that reads any individual with
the surname dwan who enters this Valley
shall be met with certain death even
Juan The Rock Johnson but despite this
dwan you bravely enters the valley there
he is greeted by a maid who guides him
to the main hall shortly after the
Empress of the valley gone bow bow walks
out from the inner hall wearing a smile
on her face however it quickly Fades
away when dwan you unintentionally
reveals his true name when she inquires
for more information about him he shares
that he hails from linan prefecture in
the southern region of the Yangtze River
and has been residing in Dali for three
years after hearing these details gone
bow bow swiftly changes the subject and
expresses her concern for her daughter
in response duanyu presents zhangling's
shoe to her further increasing her
distress as the two are talking a loud
and scary voice emanates from someone
outside the door this causes gon Bao Bao
to become scared while Duan yew remains
uncertain about what is coming towards
him the voice says do you smile what the
Drone is cooking
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching